donc là c'est les étagères tumu ce que
tu veux tu hockey et puis d'air la
caméra du coup hier stéphane et là-bas
christophe va te régler le micro au
clair tu sais que ça va aller
oui je sais mais c'est pas facile de
partir même pour de nouvelles aventures
c'est pour aller merci l'est et bien
bonjour a tous moi c'est marie et c'est
désormais à mes côtés que vous aller
savourer votre veste de science vous
m'avez peut-être d'ailleurs déjà croisé
sur internet où j'aime bien vulgariser
les sciences au travers de sujets
d'insolite
oui enfin cela me permet surtout de lire
dans l'obscurité tout le monde pense que
je peux pas me poser au sol mais c'est
juste que je veux pas vous verrez on ne
risque pas de s'ennuyer ensemble car ici
on s'intéresse à toutes les disciplines
à partir des images réalisées par les
scientifiques lors d'expériences de
modélisation ou d'observation mais ça si
vous nous suivez vous le savez déjà et
abonnez vous